my name is John Fiorelli I'm the founder
of cut and paste it started in 2005 we
did a first party bringing designers
together from the community it was
intended to be fun and chill and really
didn't really think about doing anything
very big but it was a way of celebrating
design and celebrating creative
competition like live creative
competition I think that a lot of people
don't really understand what the process
is and what it means to be a designer or
an artist so I mean this is gonna be
great for all my friends that are like
accountants that are like what do you do
oh wow you do this for eight hours a day
that's cool I think for professional
designers who come to this I think many
of them would say I don't know if I
would do this and we understand because
we think what we're asking a lot of
designers to do on stage is borderline
ridiculous to put them on stage to do 15
minutes of design in front of their
friends and their family and their
colleagues is strange but at the same
time what we're finding is that a lot of
designers are very game for it and
they're finding it to be a great
opportunity to meet new collaborators
and new clients and to reach people
creatively so while it's a little
unorthodox you think people are having
fun with it and we hope we hope we'll
continue to have fun with it
what excites me about is just the fact
that there are so many people that are
interested in what I do behind closed
doors within my little bubble and window
that have come out to see this and that
kind of gives me some like adrenaline
rush right there it's kind of like
alright let's do this let's do this now
all I need is music
I think what's good about a
constitutionally cutting pace is it it
puts a little more attention back on the
people that I actually create things you
know what really matters is the content
and the things that people make that we
watch and enjoy and it's kind of nice to
see you know that like this where you
know we're putting the attention back on
the people that make the things and I
think that's really cool